over the weekend I happened upon this
Twitter conversation that I thought I
would share with you because it touches
on philosophy and it also not only
invokes banality but manages to perform
it in funny ways so it's spurred by this
tweet what a subtitle and the subtitle
here is referring to this movie Hana
arent the subtitle being the woman who
saw banality in evil now that's a bad
subtitle for a number of different
reasons the first of which is that it
just doesn't pop it doesn't come across
well that is not something that would
make me if I didn't know anything about
philosophy or Hana or rent say oh I
should watch this movie or make my
students watch this movie either it's
also not particularly good because Hana
aran's viewpoint
isn't that evil is all banal uh she's
talking about uh Eichmann right and
she's writing about this in her reports
that later on become Eichmann in
Jerusalem she certainly thinks there's
many other kinds of evil the banality of
evil sounds kind of cool but it's not
the most important thing to know Hana
rent for
so you know this led to a quip uh a
quote tweet Kant the man who found
things to criticize in pure reason and
now this takes off right because what do
we have here we see that the person is
picking up on an aspect of an author's
work and kind of trivializing it right
and poking fun in a rather Gentle Way so
some of these are what we could call dry
humor some of these are quite banal and
there's some overlap between the two of
them so let's move on and see what
people had to say in response we begin
with the ancient period we have Socrates
the man who knew nothing okay that's
something that we know is in there in
the socratic dialogues that we have with
Plato then Socrates the main man who
apologized and there there are actually
two different apologies out there Plato
and xenophon so that works as well
definitely not the main thing that we
remember Socrates for then we have
diogenes the cynic philosopher uh a
later generation the man of featherless
biped he's reputed to have come into
Plato's
teaching place the academy and when
Plato was defining a human being as
featherless biped he took a pluck
chicken and threw it in there and said
there's a man for you then we have
Aristotle the man who is rational
Aristotle defines human being as
rational animals so this is trivially
true of Aristotle there weren't a lot of
medieval discussion uh jokes in this
case so we have this is a good one
Aquinas the man who summarized theology
referencing this
and is the summer a summary not exactly
but this joke really does work and then
this next one is even better burden the
man with the most famous ass in
philosophy and there is indeed burden's
ass it's not a bot but rather a donkey
so you know if you're not sure what's
meant they're going go ahead and look it
up and you'll find a very funny thought
experiment
then we get Descartes and notice that
people made the same joke and the joke
gets kind of stale I think the second
time around every single one of them
refers to thinking and being right some
of these are exactly the same wording
and there's so much more to Descartes
than just I think therefore I am or
jokes about not thinking or anything
like that moving on we have German
idealism and we have ficta the man who
taught science then we get two Hegel
ones and two schopenhauer ones and I
think these are pretty decent Hegel the
man who saw figures of the spirit okay
so for a Honda rent style biography that
might work Hegel the man with the
phenomenal spirits and that one works on
a couple different levels and then we
get Dowers
the man who found the thing in itself
and he does not like it then we have
schopenhauer the man who thinks this is
all a complete crap right and Chopin
hour is a pessimist so this kind of
makes sense we also have the you know
marks Engels connection marks and Engels
The Men Who manifested communism there's
a Communist Manifesto that's the joke
there then we have Marx the man who
criticized political economy and Engels
the man who is not pro during because of
course he wrote an anti during
and then we you know finish up the 19th
century more or less with a couple
Nietzsche quips and these are pretty
good nature the man who is beyond good
and evil that actually wouldn't be a bad
title then here's a great joking one
Nietzsche the man who made the science
gay referring of course to the uh
ferelict of the gay science we often
translate it and then this one's really
good too Nietzsche the man who eternally
returned it's almost the opposite of the
MTA the man who never returned nature
turns
eternally returns eternally
then we get some phenomenology the man
who went back to the things themselves
well that was his slogan wasn't it as
well as of the phenomenological movement
and then we've got two Heidegger being
time ones which are pretty close
together the man who was being in time
the man who was being all the time
subtle difference there I think those
are pretty good and then we'll get some
uh analytic philosophy in here right
Wittgenstein the man who investigated
philosophically just taking the title
philosophical investigations
anscombe the woman who intended writes
about intentionality and intentions
right stress and the man who bounded
since and then finally Brandon the man
who made it explicit so those are okay
kind of low-hanging fruit in all these
cases then we get some critical theory
from Rockford school people you notice
that we've got two Marcus basically the
same thing the man with one dimension or
the man who was one-dimensional I am
really quite surprised that nobody
picked up on any of the other weird
wacky stuff that Marcus has said and
done in his time and then we got from
the man who escaped from Freedom almost
the exact opposite of what he was
advocating and then interestingly enough
uh it looks like habermas was somehow a
big draw and and we've got three
different ones here habermas The Man Who
Saw Communication in action right he's
got communicative action as one of his
main ideas the man who structurally
transformed the public sphere uh now of
course he didn't he's discussing how it
transformed but good enough and then the
man who found the public in private
pretty good as well
uh we've got three more people you could
say within the broadly Continental
tradition
I really like this one but Ty the man
who accursed a share you know that works
that's it isn't still all of this is
low-hanging fruit but it's that one's
pretty funny uh this one's subtly funny
Duluth the same only different constant
theme of his work and then finally uh
Spivak the one who spoke for the
sub-altern one of the main Concepts that
Spivak is known for then we get a couple
that are talking about uh
Transformations or you know big picture
stuff we got John Rawls
this is as banal as you can possibly get
the man who had a theory about Justice
well his book is a theory of Justice
it's about a theory of justice that is
as dry and dull as you can get
um
the man who structured scientific
revolutions
pretty good there and then finally Lumen
the man who planned a theory of society
30 years zero cost so a few final
thoughts on my part you notice that none
of these are what we would call uh in
the parlance of the kids these days
bangers but they are kind of funny this
one did not turn out to be a laugh Riot
because I think a lot of people did in
fact go for low-hanging fruit and I
think we could probably do a lot better
with this and and maybe maybe we will
down the line maybe we'll revisit this
and come up with some really funny some
really biting some really incisive ones
and wouldn't it be cool to do this with
movie posters like the one that we've
got for this Hana arent you know looking
thoughtfully off into the distance and
the kind of script and verbiage that
movie people use but that's that's
perhaps a project for down the line I
hope this gave you a little chuckle
maybe yeah maybe maybe made you think a
little bit who knows and that is it for
this conversation